hey guys in one of my previous videos we
talked about what you should not eat on
an empty stomach so a lot of you guys
ask me Daniel all right so what should
we eat in the morning what is the best
breakfast so that's what we're going to
talk about in this video let's get to it
[Music]
all right guys to give your body what it
needs you need to eat something that is
healthy that will give your body the
good type of energy that will last so
that means first of all stay away from
all unhealthy sugary cereals is the
worst thing you can do to your body it
will spike your energy levels and it'll
just come crashing down when it's done
and then of course it can lead to
diabetes and other health conditions
you need to take this seriously a lot of
people just go and they just eat
whatever they want to eat and they don't
realize what they're doing to their
bodies and like I always say
if you have enough respect for yourself
then take care of yourself that includes
what you put in to your body just like
sugary cereals a lot of people go for
white toast in the morning don't do it
because it just turns into sugar in your
stomach and you don't get the nutrients
you need
if you do love bread I mean I love bread
if you're a bread lover then go for a
whole wheat bread and the second best
option rye bread so that you'll still
get the fiber and nutrients you need
just make sure it's not GMO bread
because that is so bad for you and if
you do eat bread in the morning healthy
bread then don't go for unhealthy stuff
on it don't go for just syrup or those
kind of stuff no the best thing you can
eat with whole wheat bread is eggs
because you get all the good stuff from
eggs and a lot of protein just don't go
over three egg yolks a day
another good option with your whole
wheat bread I love this a lot is peanut
butter some people buy almond butter but
that's a little bit more expensive so I
stick with peanut butter
with a little bit of Honey on top oh I
love it
especially with coffee and that is
another point to remember never drink
coffee before breakfast because of the
acidity so always do it with breakfast
or after breakfast now the best
breakfast the one that I love the most
oatmeal not the fake oatmeal with
different flavors and artificial stuff
no just 100 real oats let me show you
just how I make my oatmeal in the
morning first I don't add a specific
amount of oats but I roughly use a bit
less than a cup size to maintain my body
size and because of time I do not boil
it I eat it as it is I add the milk
first and leave it just for a few
minutes while I go put on my clothes so
that it soaks a bit then I come back and
I add my whey protein powder and mix it
well
next I add mixed nuts and seeds to get
the crunchy texture and to get that
healthy fat my body needs after that I
add a banana and the super fruit
blueberries
now this is my favorite way of eating
oats but you know in those days where I
don't work out I don't use whey protein
so
my B option this is what I love to do
when it comes to oats as well oats
milk
peanut butter
cinnamon
banana
and lastly some honey
you guys from South Africa will love it
as well because it says close to melkos
now if you want to know why I believe so
much in oats and why it's so healthy for
you
and check out this video here and I'll
see you there and before you go always
remember life is short so don't waste
yours Church guys